ですから集中しちゃったら他のものは知らない
聞かない 感じない で  6番目は 6番目はジーヴィチンドリと読む
ジーヴィチンドリ 日本語で名根と書いてるだろうと思いますけど
それはちょっと説明しにくいんです
皆様方にこのサンニャーとかチェータナとかわかりにくいかもしれませんだけど
私にとっては説明しやすいんです
ジーヴィチンドリはちょっと説明しにくいんです
ジーヴィチンドリというのは命という意味なんですね
命 それで心にも生きてるという働きがあるんだそうです
もう何かちょっとした働きがあって
命というふうな言葉入れちゃって
それでこの活動すると
この瞬間なんですけど
この瞬間に活動することは
もしかするとジーヴィチンドリと言っているかもしれません
それあるんだから その一つの心終わったら
また次の心をまた含まれて活動する
物質の場合もジーヴィチンドリというものを仏教で言っているんです
単なる物質であろうが
名根という物質もあるんだという
もしかするとこれはこの一つの物質がもう消えても
次の物質になっちゃうんです
物質もエネルギー働きだから
一つの働きが消えちゃうと
また新しい働きが生まれる
その働きが消えて 次の働きが生まれる
止まることなくエネルギーが流れていっちゃう
そういうふうな物質の流れと心もそういうふうに流れちゃう
一つ考えて それ終わったら次のことを考える
それ終わったら次のことを考える
じゃあこれから考えることをやめますかと認識をやめますか？ということにならないんですね
続けていっちゃう 例で言うならば
例えば球なんか持ってボールなんか持って
軽い力でちょっと投げたら
球が曲がって曲がって曲がって曲がっていって土台止まるでしょう
そういうふうに足仕事して終わって
じゃあそれでストップということは
エネルギーの法則ではないんです
我々目で見たら 球は投げた球がそこで止まったと
ストップだと言ってますけど
エネルギーの世界ではストップになったわけじゃないんです
ずっとエネルギーは流れているんです
球は止まっても それはもう球と地球の引力の駆け引きで転がっている球に対して
地球が違うエネルギーを出していて
そこは地球の方が勝ったところで球が止まるだけで
それでも球がそこにずっと止まってるんだから
そこでエネルギーは働いてるんですね
止まってるために ですから
エネルギーのこの不滅論ですか
現れてるそこのエネルギーの不滅論みたいに
この一つ消えても また他のものになると
そのファンクション その働きが
もしかするとジーヴィチンドリと言っているかもしれません
そうするとジーヴィチンドリ
2つが当然必要なんです
一つは物質に名根 もう一つは心に名根
物質と同じく心も終わることなく変化して続けちゃうんです
それはジーヴィチンドリと思う
名根 で 最後にマナスカラ
マナスカラっていうのは
心はいつでも認識しなくちゃ心ではないし
やっぱりいつでも認識しようとするんです
その認識しようとする働きがマナスカラと言うんです
用語ではサ サイと言うんですね
サイ まあそういうふうに我々が知っているものなんですけどね
チェータナとはちょっと違う
チェータナで荒っぽい説明すると
チェータナというのは何かやりたがっていることと
マナスカラ じゃあやろうということと
そのように  どこに判断が入る？ 判断とか入らないです
わかる？ジュース飲みたいなぁと
じゃあ飲もうと 飲むことしなきゃ飲みませんだから
飲みたいなというエネルギーはチェータナという
そこでいわゆる行動に行くところ
そこをまなちからなければ行動は生まれません
で こういう 7つは本当はこの心素であって
どんな心にもある まぶたを閉じてまぶたを開けた瞬間にこの 7つもあるというんです
一生 だから我々は自動的に見ていると思ってますけど
自動的に見ているんじゃなくて
見たいんだから見ているんです
見たいというエネルギーもあって
じゃあそれだったら見ようということも働きもあって
で 心が自由意思で目を通って活動もしていて
そこで見たいものに触れて
触れたことは感じて 感じたものには区別判断して
それ全部一緒に起こる
起こったら認識というものがある
見たということは生まれるんです
聞いたという実感が生まれる
見たというのは結果 その見たという結果が生まれるために
この 7つが活動する 心の中で
で 私が知っているヨーロッパ型の心理学っていうのは
大体そこら辺で終わります
もうちょっとムスぐらいありますけど
そのぐらいの心相でほとんど終わりますけど
でもこんなに明確に見てないんですね
で ここで言うのは 我々には受
受が自我の問題 感じるんだから自我があると思う
じゃあ感じるとやめられますかと
やめられません 生きている感じは
ずっと認識しているんです
物に触れるとそれ感じちゃいますから
感じたものは何が何を感じたか
また知る で 感じたら何を感じたかと
そうすると何をするべきかというのが出てきて
それからそこで集中して
心の働きでそのことをしてしまっちゃう
いわゆるわかりやすく目をを開けた瞬間で
光の情報体に触れる 触れた瞬間で見て終わっちゃう
そこで言葉入る世界じゃないんです
言葉入る前にもう見て終わってるんです
言葉にするのは別の頭の働きで
見たのは絵ですよ 綺麗ですよ
嫌ですよと それには膨大な認識の働きが生まれなくちゃいけないんです
でね 目を開けた瞬間でもう十七回ぐらい心が生まれて消えてるんです
その十七回の中でこういうものは生まれて消えていくんです
ですから 見る心は違う
見たものは何であろうかと判断する心
また違う 心とはまた違うことなんです
判断について行動しようとする心
また違う でもどんな心にもその七つがあるんです
その七つ揃ったところで認識というものがあります
そこでわかりやすくするためにと
このそれを一つわかったらすべてはわかるんだと
だから宇宙の研究するんじゃなくて
それを一つ捕まってみたら
すべての宇宙は何でしょうかとわかるということで
そういうふうにこの言葉を入れてるんです
だからファッサは触れる
その瞬間のファッサわかったら
我々の体にコンタクトするすべてがわかったことになっちゃう
それをわかってないんだから
それは神様とのコンタクト
異次元の存在とのコンタクトとかしちゃう
それで自分がちょっと違いますとか
ずれてるんだとか ああだこうだといろんなことを妄想する
でもコンタクトはどういうものかというと
触れることだけですよと見たら
すべてのものは全部コンタクトしかないとわかる
たとえ神様の声を聞いたっても
聞いたものはすぐ感じなくちゃいけない
だから感じを感じることから見れば全部同じです
例えば 人間の認識はどういうものですか？人間の知識はどういうものですか？記憶力の問題はどういうものですか？とか
いろんな本があるでしょうに
でも それのレベルでサンニャーという働き
見る 聞く 味わう瞬間に
そのものはどんな差を持ってるかと
そこに入っている そこは膨張大になって考えちゃうと
記憶力 能力はああだこうだと言うんです
だから普通の世界では記憶力についていろいろ本があったりとか
どうすれば記憶力は集中力が増えますかとか
そこでなんかみんな迷信的なものになっちゃうんですね
何か抜群の記憶力があればいいんじゃないか
ものすごい鋭く集中力があればいいんじゃないかとか
いろんなことを考えますけど
そこら辺に考えちゃうと真理はわからなくなる
現象の世界で考えちゃいますから
ですから 原子レベルでこういうものが起こりますよ
だから原子レベルだから原子に使う言葉を使わないで
我々日常生活で使っている言葉
用語としてわざと使っているんです
で サンニャーっていうのは
そうっていうのは まあなんて今言った言葉
知覚 知覚とかね そういうよく一般的にインプレッションとか
どんな言葉で言うんだけど
そういう言葉で理解するものと同じですよ
そこでなんで僕で決断
判断という言葉が出てこないかというと
こういう働きはまた働いて働いて
その働いている過程に判断と言うんです
判断という現象があるわけじゃないんです
だから判断は当てにならない
判断という現象あるならば
誰でも同じ判断するはずでしょうし
で 認識過程で自分の方向へ行っちゃう
例えば音を聞いた その聞いた音について
ある人は自分に馴染みのある音かもしれません
ある人には珍しい音かもしれません
それはその人のサンニャーによりますでしょ
で 珍しい音と思った人はまた違う判断する
馴染みのある音だとサンニャーの人が違う判断する
判断というのは妄想の回転ですね
見たもの聞いたものについてどのような妄想をしているかということは人の判断であって
ですから仏教ではそれは妄想だから判断という現象がないんです
まああの何時まで もう時間過ぎました
一応ちょっと難しいんだけど
ここら辺理解してほしいんです
ここら辺は一番大事なところ
じゃ あの また次にいろいろ質問してくださいよ
わからないところはいろいろ
そこら辺